le titre de champion inter académique de
handball s'est joué ce mercredi 19 avril
à plaisir
l'association sportive du lycée jean
vilar recevait au gymnase de nicholas
l'heure les lycées de paris et de
montereau objectif décrocher une
qualification pour les championnats de
france unss
douze élèves plaisir moi actuellement en
seconde et en première ont participé à
la compétition
c'est là le niveau il est moins élevé
qu'en club quand même mais il reste
quand même bon sur l'équipe de paris
nous on est un peu au dessus
physiquement aussi
mais sinon après cet accouchement s'agit
bien c'est assez important quand même
même si c'est un championnat qui est
moins fort que ce qu'on pratique en club
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on tient à
coeur parce qu'on est des compétiteurs
et on fait absolument gagner ce tournoi
est aussi l'occasion de mettre en
pratique les deux heures de cours
dispensées chaque mercredi depuis début
septembre où dans le lycée moi je suis
dans le questionnement je les fait
réfléchir sur le jeu je les fais
intervenir dans les temps morts je les
fais intervenir à la mi temps pour avoir
leurs ressentis savoir ce qu'il faut
changer et c'est pas c'est pas moi qui
donne toutes les informations j'essaie
de les mobiliser alors au sens tactique
et réfléchie du jeu pour que y ait un
vrai apprentissage pas l'équipe de
plaisir a finalement terminé deuxième
après sa défaite 23 9 contre le lycée
montereau un classement qui leur permet
d'accéder au championnat de france unss
la compétition devrait se dérouler fin
mai màj
[Applaudissements]